has gotten some
I can't say that okay I'm gonna let the
clip say it you got some balls kid yeah
Gino reacts after Jasmine tells him she
cheated on him with her ex Dane and has
video
and I'm going back to him yeah go back
yeah
it's a mess let's talk about it
okay 90 day fans fam it's melissia all
right let's get into how Gino and
Jasmine went from this is spa day
so I'm gonna clean your face first to
this you want to see a video of me with
that
I don't know whether to believe her or
not at the top of the episode Jasmine
gives Gino a spa treatment the Hat
we know Gino does not play about the Hat
one two three Boop hopefully one day
he'll get over the insecurity he has
about his head we've already seen it
free the Hat better yet you know
for your scalp you got this bald is
beautiful yes
let me see how much better look at she
is so cute
at this point in the season Gina was
about to leave Panama and return to
America so he can work Jasmine of course
doesn't want him to go baby why are you
going to stay
let me enjoy the massage why are we have
to talk about this because
yours like that when it's time to say
goodbye to your boo while it was kinda
cute at first things take a turn when
Jasmine brings up how she's frustrated
that her K1 visa to get to the U.S is
taking so long maybe it has been 13
months
yeah but we had the pandemic that we had
to go through which
skills for everything no but it's true
baby I want you to say baby I cannot
live without you let's find a way to be
together
super fast what is he gonna do override
the government okay so I'm not gonna
have my man
life will you then at least be willing
to help me pay for this apartment until
the gay one gets approved
I'm not sure if Jasmine is asking for
help meaning that she pays for some of
the rent and he pays for some of it or
if she's asking him to continue to pay
for it all
remember this is a luxury building
around three thousand dollars a month
it's also the same building where her ex
Dane lives the Australian Prince
Charming
concrete can get a good apartment for 15
minutes or two thousand no
I know that he can afford it so paying
for the apartment until the Visa comes
through shouldn't be an issue
but for me it is not just about the
apartment
do you know have had so many
opportunities to show me that I am his
priority you know like high an
immigration lawyer for our K-1 Visa pay
for this apartment so I can stay here
while I wear for the gay One Visa but he
won't do any of that and I'm sick of it
he's probably sick of it too Jasmine
it's money coming out of his pocket
these are my thoughts yes we know
Jasmine loves nice things she likes the
High Life nothing's wrong with that but
if it isn't your money you're spending
this isn't your husband yet y'all don't
have any kids and you're not his
financial advisor in my opinion
I don't think you have the right to tell
him how he should spend his money and
just because you can afford something
doesn't mean you should buy it
I don't think that's the best mindset to
have when it comes to finances we get
you a good place don't worry
this I want this place Gino said oh
she's not really hearing me can you get
can you grab your phone let me come look
for an apartment no could you please say
yes for once to me Jasmine don't do that
he said yes when he got you the
apartment the first time you sound a
little spoiled
Jasmine says oh you want to call me
spoiled when there was a time when you
signed up to be a sugar daddy to Sugar
Babies
yeah it's go time for her when I met you
you have money for Sugar Babies you were
paying 300 for dates you have money for
your ex you took her to Disney
Disneyland is she serious for a one-way
vacation you pay more that I'm begging
you one month yeah I'm not sure if you
can compare a one week Disney trip that
he was also a part of to paying a
month's worth of rent just for you to
live in one of Panama's most luxurious
Apartments when there are other
comfortable options
trash
y'all this episode was the first time I
can recall seeing Gino fire bags so
intensely at Jasmine it's like he was
matching her energy a part of me thought
yes stand up Gino but the other side was
like whoa he is fighting fire
with fire this is most expensive place
get out of here get and then get off my
place this is not the first time Jasmine
has told Gino to get out of her place
and I find it fascinating how not once
has he told her I pay for this apartment
this is my house you get out not saying
he should tell her that I'm just saying
it's interesting how he's not let those
words come out of his mouth
I wanna take your
dog look at Jasmine
okay how do you like that okay okay how
do you like that what is this get out of
my way no get out of life
oh Gino's fingers we're about to be done
get out
don't be throwing
thank you oh she is really upset right
now this huge tantrum because he won't
pay for a three thousand dollar a month
apartment and if she really wants to get
her way I don't see why her first
inclination is not to be sweet to soften
him up to get him to say yes that way
instead it's exploding on him and saying
the worst possible things you can say to
a human being
better yet your lover meanwhile Gino is
hiding behind the door
look nope don't come out yet
I wonder what the neighbors are thinking
and her vocal cords goodness gracious
can Jasmine sing she has to be able to
sing
well
are you today wow she says she wants him
to die I don't care how mad you are if
you ever tell me that
we're not cool
you're officially in the past
it's done
Gino say it I pay for this house
let me stop that would be Petty true but
Petty
[Music]
I'm done with this
the electric toothbrush Saga this is the
second time one of those things has
ended up on the ground after a Jasmine
explosion
[Music]
wow
that toothbrush was in the dirt fast
forward Jasmine eventually comes out of
her room to talk to Gino I'm tired dude
I'm so tired
look she has her dog all worried I don't
see that you wanna be with me I don't
see that you wanna help me to make this
process easier like I am so scared of
going to USA of going to the USA I told
y'all I bet Jasmine can sing I am so a
scared of going to USA
when I I am not gonna have family I'm
just gonna have you and you every time
that I ask you for financial help this
is your reaction
how about for the last two and a half
years supporting you with money and when
are you gonna give me credit for that
Jasmine then goes on to say Gino isn't
acknowledging the sacrifices she's
making to move to the U.S that gets me
insighted
me this is the country where I was born
in and I'm I'm happy here and I have to
say goodbye to everything like you don't
understand that and then you have this
attitude with me and you are like the
only person I want to have there what if
you treat me so badly there
I'm not gonna treat you bad if you treat
me badly I do not I do not take you bad
here I was giving you
oh God I would do a flashback to see who
started yelling first but
there's no point we know who's tripping
here during their confessionals to the
cameras the two continue to argue when
Jasmine says Geno prioritizes his money
and family above her well I would say
it's a tie
for my family and Jasmine
are you serious
she's tied with my family
what am I doing with you
if I'm not the most important person in
your life yeah after marriage you would
marriage
I'm not prioritizing anybody who talks
to me like that
[Music]
can you say a little louder I can't hear
you
right that's you
I think my family's important
brains in your head I'm not the feminine
anymore they need to be on the last
resort season two
things escalate even more when Gino
walks off after Jasmine calls him an
idiot
family thrush
right there [__]
Gino called her a [__] I've never heard
him say that he's the best man that I
have ever had and I'm going back to him
yeah go back yeah
it is the most important person
go to hell
I was once told by a wise person that
words either build or break down a
relationship some things that are said
you're never going to be able to forget
and these two are sitting here competing
trying to say the worst possible things
to each other you want to see a video of
me
Jasmine one go ahead
[Music]
oh is that true then go I swear to God
or
she don't brought God into it
all of this because he won't pay for her
luxury apartment
I don't want to see you know I don't
even wanna be friends with the same
oxygen
this is it
is it
we'll see I spoke to Jasmine in May and
asked her if she cheated on Gino with
Dane she also reacted to the moment that
just went down people have different
definitions of cheating you know there
is microchipping that is actually
cheating there is okay like this what
you did and Gino did it how would you
react
I will be pissed I will be mad and but
my definition of cheating is like you
look another person you're cheating on
me okay so
in using my own definition of cheating
I have to be fair to you know like
you're cheating on me at the moment
according to my own destination maybe
but yes that that I told you know what
was very very bad you don't tell that to
a man even if that was true or not that
was that was the lowest of the low it
was they were saying a lot of hurtful
things to each other how are you going
to be lovers and enemies
anyway next week it looks like David is
popping the question to Sheila and he's
so nervous it literally shows
[Music]
that man is sweating
wow Sheila was like it's not that hot
I can't wait to see it all right 90 day
fans fam thanks for hanging with me make
sure you stick with E.T because we are
covering it all I will see you next time